Right, that means something. Right.
That's, that's impressive to me.
I think that's really impressive.
There are a lot of performers
who are not good performance.
They start out not as good performance
and they need the people to believe in
them in order to get away with a
trickery. Right. And they never lose that.
They always want people to
believe it's a trigger. And when,
so when I started coming out and I started
saying, Hey, it's magic, it's verbal,
it's nonverbal communications,
all this stuff mixed together to
create a show on not a psychic.
There is absolutely nothing
psychic about what I do.
There were quite a few mentalist
in the mentalism field back then.
There wasn't as many as they
are now who were upset with me.
Dunkin said if you are assigned take man,
the best way to hide it is say you're
not assigned like right. Yeah. No,
that would be true except it's not
the case. So what's up with the nails?
I don't know cause we're
two hours in here. Maria,
tell me what's up with these nails.
Yeah, take a nail. Okay. All right.
All right. So this is what
I want you to do. I just,
you're going to have to
describe what's happening. Okay.
So this is one of the very first
things I started doing. Joe,
is this like the nail,
I want you to look at the nail and nail
and I want you to watch what happens.
Okay. I'm watching what happens.
Oh my God, you're bending it.
This is incredible. You're Ben. As you
can see, the nail is actually slowly,
slowly bending out ranges. I look
at, he's shaking your hand too.
Yeah. Showing your powers. And the
thing about that, take a look at it.
It's not a trick nail. It's
nothing like that. I mean,
everything I use from silverware to forks
to anything that I do is a actual like
this and slowly do that. Nah,
that's it's uh, yeah, no,
but I'll straighten it out
again. I was at the VA,
I was at the very end right there like
that. Oh, I can't, I can't do that.
So here, hold on. You got
another one maybe? Yeah,
I'm gonna say, yeah, let's keep it got
some forks. Yeah, I got some forks. Okay.
So I want you, I want you to point to
a fork. Anyone? Um, how about this one?
Do you want it or you want me to have
that one? Uh, I'll take that one.
You'll take it. All right.
So, so you've heard of people,
we've talked about people actually
bending silverware, right?
Can I have that pen that said? Wow.
That one. You know, you can't. Yeah,
I don't know. That's the one I want.
I'm getting you to do something.
I this one, just give me them fucking for
the time. This, I know what you doing.
Give me that fork. Yeah, you got a fork.
They'll take a whole shit for it. No,
you can have that fork.
Joe. Let's take your fork.
Joe. Trying to get this floor to
Ben. You know, watching, um, yeah,
this was year four. Incredible. Trying
to get this one. The could have burned.
[inaudible]
what kind of techniques are you
using, sir? There's a check.
Tell me and I'll trick forks. Well,
we're going to eat with these prompts.
Those are those actually
100% genuine forks. Um,
but you can't tell me how you're
doing it. It's slight of hand.
That's as much as I can tell you.
Okay. Let me do it. Do it again.
So I would watch some more time. You
want to watch one more time? Okay.
I was hoping I had like a bullshit
fake fork. No, not really. Are legit.
If I was sitting with you, I'll
show you it. It's actually, no,
it's easier if I'm sitting with you.
So let's do here. People can tell, huh?
Yup. So what's this one? Ready? Here
we go. Watch it. Right. Watch. Okay,
so I'm going to shake it like right.
You know what? Let's do it this way.
Can you, is it a way, can I move this?
Yeah. Yeah. So hold both hands out
like this. Okay. And I'm just going to,
I'm going to hold it right there.
I want you to hold that in and hold that
in for me. I'm gonna have to make a,
what do you want me to do? Hold
this end as well. Okay. With that.
And I'm going to hold it right
in the center. Right there. Okay.
You're rubbing it. Watch, Oh, you're
heating it up. Wait, wait. Don't, don't,
don't, don't, don't force it.
Don't force it. Just hold it. Okay.
Can you feel that? Yeah. Because it's a
different kind of metal. No, it's not.
Yeah.
You're using some sort of fake
ass metal and now it's hard again.
Right? Because you're heating it up,
right? Is that what it is? No. What?
I'm going to actually get this one a
break. Hmm. But I'm gonna look now chill.
Wow. Right? Because it's some bullshit
ass metal. I promise you it's not.
I have DVDs out that teach
magicians how to do this. Of course,
you gotta be a magician. Know where to
get it. And it uses any fork anywhere.
Anytime. Promise you.
But I got mine to bend now.
Yeah. Good luck bending it
this way. If they were
made out of special metal,
I would never let you keep them
because they would be too expensive.
But this one's going to twist all the
way around and that one's not made as
special metal. It's a regular metal. Hold
on. I've got to concentrate. Yo, dude,
are you psychic for real? Yeah.
What kind of wizardry is that, sir?
He spun this around and turned into a not,
the thing is he's not going to tell you
how he does it. That's the real problem.
No, you're telling me that it's bullshit,
but you won't tell me how you're doing
this bullshit. It's very unfortunate.
What? There's different techniques.
That's the thing, right? I mean,
and I really hope you can come see a show.
Sometimes I do things like one
person, another person feels it.
I tell people to donate like name and
number, you know any number at all. Okay,
go ahead. 13. Okay.
And that would be a common number for a
lot of people to choose. Sure. You know,
there were specific words, if I said
to you, think of a number of name,
any word with seven letters or
less. Go ahead. Okay, go ahead. Cut.
Of course. Most people wouldn't.
Most people were not a common
word. No, that's not a common word.
I'd know most people are choosing
love or how something like that.
And kinda along those lines, uh, you
know, a dog or cat, a really common ones.
Um, but, but here's, here's the
interesting thing. Okay. Okay.
So inside this wallet, did you give up
on the word? Because I'd chosen her.
There was no, no. Yeah, inside
this wallet. I put it in, see,
I was driving while I was driving
all around it. Right, right.
And someone cut you off and
you know what doodling is?
Doodling is when you kind of
scribble without even looking.
And as you notice inside the hair, you
open it up. Tell me what's on there.
So you know, I didn't want to
touch it. What does it say?
It's hard to read. Yeah, it's
my handwriting and doodling.
Does it say 13 and can't?
Yeah, it does. Let me see.
Oh shit. Hmm. Well,
it's such bad handwriting that I got to
think that you wrote that underneath the
table. It is definitely a 13 right?
[inaudible] yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wrote it under the table
while we're doing this.
How would it end up inside the wallet?
Cause you just shoved it in there. Oh,
this is, try this. What's that
one? All right, we'll try this.
I can't promise I'm going to be
able to do okay. You know what?
I got both of you in here. Let's
do this. What am we do? All right.
I just got a bunch of cards on
second deck of cards. All right.
That is crazy though, to have 13 and
cunt written on the piece of paper.
I'm gonna wash your hands closer. I'm
going to fan of cards out, Joe. Okay.
I'm not going to actually have
you pick one up. I am in sort of,
I'm going to find it. I'm not good at
fanning cause I'm not a magician. Right.
I'm gonna show you the cards. You're not
a magician. I'm a mentalist. Oh, watch.
I'm going to found the cards out.
I want you to think of any card you
see any card. I say you get one. Okay.
You see it? Yes. Did you get a red card?
Excuse me? Did you get a red card? Yes.
Good. Did she got a red card? And we
do. Same with you across the table.
I want you to think of any card to get a
black card. Okay. Do you get one? Yeah.
All right.
I'm gonna ask one question cause I have
to ask questions sometimes to try to
figure out exactly what it
is you're thinking. Okay.
Did either one of you
choose a high card? Yes. No.
Okay. High cards are hard for me to get,
but I will try. All right. Look at me.
Don't dump down so you got a red card.
I'm going to say your
card is probably hearts.
Your card over there. Jamie is black. Yes.
Probably spades.
Nailed it.
The two, two of spades.
Yes.
Hearts, King hearts. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, let me see that deck of cards.
We only had three choices. Yeah.
I had a queen of spades and eight of
spades and a two of spades and I switched
from the queen of sprays. Before you
asked that question, high or low?
I went low. You went low. You went
low. Yeah. Why did you do that?
Because I thought it was [inaudible]
mind. Fuck he mind fucked.
You thought I was going to go high.
There's a lot of these kinds of things.
It's verbal, nonverbal. It's magical.
Psychology is a mixture of all kinds of
different things. Twisted up a spoon.
It son that shouldn't, yeah.
I don't know how you did that.
I definitely want you to come. We go to
the magic castle tonight, by the way,
are you? Yeah. You're welcome to call
me if I can go to the comedy store.
Oh yeah, you're working.
Yeah. Yeah, I'm working.
What time you work in there rather
come and see you so I'm not working.
You're not? Nah. Going to go
ahead and see some friends.
Like my friend of my scrubs is actually
a good friend of mine, Steve Valentine.
I don't know if you know
Steve as an actor. No,
I don't really graves' and
crossing Jordan, stuff like that.
And he's got an interesting story about
his life and it's not the psychological
thing as well,
which I'm always fascinated with of
where he was performing magic for years,
constantly performing magic and um,
he wanted to be an actor and the magic
was kind of a side thing for him,
but it started getting away. He'd go
on interviews and stuff and they say,
you know, I want you, that
guy that does kit shows,
I want you to do a party for me and so
forth. And he could never get the part.
So he started denying
that he was a magician.
I just totally left magic
completely. And people say, yeah,
I got your business card. No, that's
not me. That wasn't me. Oh wow.
That's when he started to be on how to
act and he started getting the acting
jobs and everything.
It wasn't until years later that he
could go back and be a performer. Wow.
And it's a really interesting story,
but he does it with magic and
teaching and things and yeah.
Do you ever work on comedy and magic
in her Masa? Nah. No. I never have. No.
Yeah, it's interesting cause he
mixes comedy and magic together.
Like you'll have like a magician
on the show with comedians.
There was a few of those back in the
days that I worked where it was comedy
magic club type thing. So
yeah, it's a good nights.
Do you ever teach this stuff? I
teach to other magicians. I have,
so have to be like, I have videos
and stuff. I have books. Uh,
so I definitely do teach, but I don't
teach one on one. I never teach.
I just don't have time
to teach you one on one.
I'm always so busy working and
trying to teach like this stuff.
Like how do you do these things? The
metal bending, I have DVDs out on that.
The teach magicians how to do
that. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I promise you they are not trick
forks. Those, they're not trick nails,
not trick forks. They are. Yeah.
Well just the fact that you could spin
a regular fork, right? This, Oh fuck.
Are you doing that man?
There was a way it sorta became
the Holy grail for me when a,
I can tell you how that came about for me.
There was muscle walkie I told you that
he could actually put it under a chair
and he would put it in
something and twist it.
I was doing an article
for the national Inquirer.
I don't even think I could
do that with just my hands.
And that's what's confused. And the guy
shows up. You? Yeah, there is a way.
And the guy shows up, a photographer
shows up from me and he says,
I want you to bend some silverware. So
you know, I go, Oh, you know, and I,
you know, I go to him, you
know, and I go, okay, all right,
I'm going to bend something.
So I take one and I go like this and
next thing you know it's bending up like
that. And then I do another
bend for him. He says,
this is going to take a while, isn't
it? I go, well, yeah, you know, he says,
just bend them up with your
hands. I go, well that's cheating,
which exactly what I was doing, you
know? So I say these, that's cheating.
So he says, no, go ahead. So just start
bending them up like crazy, crazy.
And next thing you know,
I had a twist and I remembered
exactly how I got that twist.
So I called Randy up on the phone because
it was sort of the Holy grail thing,
looking for a way to actually do it.
And I went in there and I had one of
those telephones that had the long cord,
you know, all the way into the bathroom.
And I called Randy up and I'm
whispering now and say, Hey,
I just bet a four with them, you
know, with my hands, you know,
just put a twist in it. And he goes,
yeah, so what? I go, no, no, no.
And I explained exactly how to do it.
And now all the mentalists
use that technique. Yeah.
So this was a regular fork. Yes.
And you twisted that right in front
of my face with one. Yes. Yup. Hmm.
Oh, how the fuck you did it.
You're not supposed to know.
He's supposed to enjoy the
mystery, Joe. All right,
well I'm trying know that you can
be fulled. It's very confusing.
I can be fooled so easily
because this is a real fork.
I know that there's a certain forks
that they make out of shitty metal.
It's like a knee, heat it up and
it becomes like super bendy. Yeah.
That's something that's, I don't want to
get too much into methods and so forth,
but that's definitely not something
I use or would use and yeah,
and that looks just a little
weird. Yeah. But yeah,
it looks like jerking off before,
but I'm trying to get a dyno monic
ejaculation that may or may not do it.
The thing about was weird is that how
easy that fork bent when I bend it,
when you had it, it was very strange.
The one that bent really easy.
When I bend it and you said,
are you doing it on your own?
It was so easy to bend, right? Like why
would it, why was it so easy to bend?
And I'm can't tell you why at
that moment, but if you look now,
that's that fork right there.
And take a look at it and
see if it's easy to bend.
Now you'll see that it's not
going to heat in as fuck her up.
I'm going to make it easy, but
it's because at that moment,
that's the one that I was going to
break. I wanted to break that one.
It's very confusing. Yeah, it's
a job. Well, it's amazing really,
because you'll let people
actually touch the things.
And someone like me who knows
that you're doing a trick,
cause you just told me that you're doing
a trick and yet I still can't figure
out how to fucking do it. You see me work,
you'll see I throw everything across the
stage and a lot of stuff I just leave
for people afterwards because I want
them to interact with those things I want
them to take them home with.
Yeah, yeah. No, I can imagine.
Especially the forks. Yeah. After
awhile, you know, that's just,
he just sat. I mean you just sit
and look at this fork afterwards.
You look okay. I don't
think I could do that. Yeah.
I mean if I just gave you a regular
fork, Jamie, do you think you'd do that?
Spin that? No, I don't think I
could twist that thing like that.
We remember when we're
talking about the TV show,
we're talking about the TV
show earlier, the areas.
I have a pitch that's out
right now for a series,
which it looks like you
may be going somewhere.
So I don't want to say too much about it,
but it's bringing back the million dollar
challenge and it's going out to James,
Randy, James,
Randy million-dollar challenge and
used to go out looking for psychics,
testing them on a proper controls.
If they're trying to trick us,
maybe I'll expose it in methods.
I will demonstrate my abilities supposedly
to do the exact same thing under
certain conditions as well and it's sort
of what makes me the expert to go out
and try to find these things and see
what's really going on and it's sort of
brain games Meech meets the
bunking meets psychic phenomena,
but not every single one is
going to be debunking either.
It's only going to be really debunking
when somebody is purposefully going out
and trying to bullshit
somebody and trying to fall.
People will take advantage of
people. It's very baffling stuff.
The the, I mean the, the,
the stuff about talking to people and ask
them questions and reading their cues.
That kind of makes sense. But
this doesn't make sense at all.
The fork stuff just does not make sense.
It's really weird because the PK
stuff is something as a mentalist,
as a performer, you tend to pick
your powers, right? You tend to,
well you wouldn't because you don't,
you know, but as performance ourselves,
when we perform this type
of stuff, we go, okay,
does that fit sort of in the repertoire
of my abilities? Do I have x-ray vision?
You know, I drive cars blindfolded,
you know, it put DOE in there,
they put tape over,
they at least see me do something
along those times on your show.
And it says thing of like,
you pick your abilities and this doesn't
seem to fit with anything except that
your Yella did do this.
And also said that it could duplicate
pictures and read minds once in a while as
well. I didn't do too much of the minor
eating, but did a little bit of it.
Somebody would draw a picture,
then he would draw a picture
and they would match. So,
which is a standard
mentalism magic trick anyway,
but his methods were a little bit
more bold, a little bit more direct.
[inaudible] yeah. I'm still
baffled, stopped being baffled.
How can I not be bent
some forks, man. Maybe.
Maybe someday I'll teach you how to do
all this and I'll tell everybody no,
they did not want that. I won't tell
you. Don't tell them. I can't tell you.
You can't tell me cause I'll
fucking tell everybody. Yeah.
But then nobody's going to be impressed
when you do it. Well, I don't care.
Yeah. I just want everybody to know.
Is there anything else that you
can do that's fucked up? Ah,
I didn't really bring a whole lot cause
I've kind of just wanted to talk more
than anything else. Um, I mean we've
done enough. It's very, very impressive.
Maybe I can do one thing for
you. Okay. I don't know. Um,
all right. So see these, you
know what they are, right? No,
they're the Zener cards. Basically.
The [inaudible] shapes basically
five shapes that were, um,
they were used at Stanford research
Institute. Uh, I took university,
actually not Stanford, Duke university.
They accredited by [inaudible]. Uh,
simple shapes. Uh, there's a
square, there's a star wavy lines,
a plus in a circle. All right. These
are the standard shapes right there.
I'm going to try to get you to choose
a specific one. Now, psychologically,
if I asked you to choose one,
which, which would you say like,
I mean we shouldn't even say
psychological [inaudible] that would be
psychological because it's right in
the middle and that would be the one.
All right, so I'm going to go with,
um, yeah, I'm going to go with a star.
I think star, there's a circle. There's
a square, a the plus in the wavy lines,
right? I'm going to mix them up so you
don't know which is which. Alrighty.
I'm going to have to look at them in
just a second myself to make sure I know
exactly where that is. All right.
We can do this as the gambling thing
or not, but I don't like to do that.
I should probably rip people off strong.
Right? Put that in the right place.
Okay, good. So this is
what we're going to do.
I'm going to take cars
and I'm going to ask you,
do you think the star is that card you,
all you have to do is not choose a star.
You're going to choose a star. You
won't know why you choose a star,
but you will choose the
star. All right? Okay.
You won't have Aegis will and
it's going to be something I do.
Something I say or something that it's
going to be something that I'm going to
try it. I just made this make me pick
the star. This may or may not work.
All right, but we're going to try. I
see sneaky pastor, do you think this is,
do you think I'm going to say yes? That's
the star. You say yes, that's a star.
You'll see. Okay, so
you're supposed to say no,
that's not the star at
some point because you,
your idea is not to pick the star. I
want you to not pick the store to anyone,
so if you think that's the
star. All right, I will. Okay,
so you're just going to say, do you
understand? Yes. All right, so here we go.
I know you're watching me close. All
right, so let's do it again. Hold on.
We already flipped them around.
It makes them up. One more time.
There's this sneaky hand movements
are still confusing. Watch. Okay.
No take time. Moments to makes me sad.
He spent so much time learning
how to move your hands like that.
So I'm gonna, I'm gonna keep it
simple. Really simple for you. Okay.
By my opinion. Yeah.
Well I've cut it already so cause I
want to do it again because I'm going to
make, make it very vague. Right.
Your job is to not choose the star
K not choose the star. Okay. Ready?
All right. So, um, um, I guess I'll
just ask you, do you want this card? No.
All right. So you don't want
that one. Don't want that one.
Do you want that card right?
Like don't choose a star.
Yes, I want that one. You sure
that's the one you want? Yeah,
that's the one I want. Don't look
okay. I won't look that. Look.
I don't trust you. Watch my hand.
Don't look, don't look okay.
I see what you didn't choose.
You didn't choose a circle,
right as she was a plus that didn't,
she was [inaudible] the wavy lines or
the square. He chose a star. They look
sound of a bitch. Yeah. Yeah, but
that's like slight of hand, right?
Huh? Huh? Well, what the hell is that?
Watch. What are you talking about?
Slight of hand. I can try. I can
try it one more time. Hold on. Okay.
To put it there. All right.
I hate doing this stuff like this because
especially with the amount of people
that are listening to this
podcast, right? What happens?
[inaudible] I'll manage if I'm
wrong. I looked like an idiot.
If you're wrong as a performer.
Yeah. Somehow or another.
I think you're not going to be
wrong. I could be. So once again,
I'm going to try and make you
choose a star, okay? Okay.
Your job is to not use it. Okay. I'm
not going to do it again after this.
This is the last time we doing this.
All right. Do you want that card? Yes.
That's the one you want. That's
the one I want. I keep in mind.
You did that the first time.
Yeah, right. Don't look,
I don't want look square.
Circle plus wavy lines.
Take look. Dammit.
The story now, do you, um,
realize that I'm impulsive
and that I have no patience?
I did all that for the star
immediately did it the first time. See,
you thought that by doing it again,
that I would not think that
you would do it a second time.
Is that what you did is that's how
you sort of kind of, not what I did.
I was not going to tell him. So now he's
getting frustrated, right? No, no, no.
I'm very impressed. I'm very
impressed. Well, listen, man,
this was a lot of fun. It was.